and a car
[Laughter]
accident you're an animal saw an
opportunity there's no other name say to
say Trevor really like Derpy like
TW but I know get get wow
okay guy who did want
to running away and you didn't pull out
a knife hello I'm I'm innocent
I'm Jesus you failed
metal doors what's hiding behind them
what do you think death leaving oh
Jesus I am armed I am
armed you silly man I would have thrown
it if I knew you had the gun no s Mak
saggy tits they're look exactly the same
now he's having a difficult time
deciding who to shoot wow you're all the
same character am I the same character
Mel whoa you he's the Kill The
Outsider
take this you assh oh look at that quad
feed
man did I kill everyone oh my god well
obviously out on top of a television
you're more than welcome to join me oh
wow I thought I killed everyone see I no
I got away I got away living my life
yeah I feel like keep the uh the crazy
bald man bloodline clean so I had to
kill him he wasn't the murderer hey over
here excuse me over here
uhoh listen we can we can sit down don't
throw that knife I know what you're
doing you're charging up that knife
aren't you Mark I don't you
dare I am not Mark I am not that's
that's real Mark Sally's Dead Oh is oh I
should have guessed from the lack of
throwing and killing
oh okay here's the deal Hut I'm gonna
stand up here and you try to kill
okay nice try there I want the oh [__]
what do you want T what are you looking
for want the knife you want the
knife this is like a speed situation I
can shoot both of you with a
66% chance that oh God God hey there you
go that was a delay throwing it I was
going to throw it it didn't work really
God damn it you pulled out your knife
like 20 yards away from me it was lag it
was lag it was laging and it didn't work
listen hey I lost my knife I I'm not a
bad guy oh okay wait what please kill MO
is everyone de is everyone dead I was
over here on the other Barn trying to
work it oh no mo is in the barn no he's
not which Barn he's to to your left is
not in the barn to your left he's hiding
there why are you telling me that you
lied to
me that he made some really bad
choices I saw that really I gave clear
instructions I gave clear
instructions don't use Clues to
determine who the murderer is just use
your heart that's all you need oh okay
so your heart May sometimes be incor my
heart states that this guy following me
might just be the okay you're all here
I'm the murderer use
your point to
me oh
crap right before my vision went dark I
saw a knif running on me I don't I don't
need you to stab me please
I've watched enough of your MW2 videos
you're not [__] moving from down
there he's camping now I'm not camping
strategy come one another no wait wait
wait wait he just wants to make you an
OM congratulations that how did I miss
that hi okay we're all here we're all
friends we all trust each other except
for you two who are shouting for help
but we all respect each
other
I just
realized I feel I feel this is cathartic
I'm good now I feel good you guys can
just kill me I don't care just gonna
freak
out wait can I can I come on you is that
is that can yeah okay get on someone get
on top of my head someone get on top
head we should go over to the boxes yeah
let's get higher and higher oh that
looks jump that looks uh dubious keep
going you are actually getting higher as
you can take everyone on top go over
here go over here oh onto the barn okay
hold on so now I can jump from the boxes
so like someone can jump on someone else
no you guys stay down there yeah
here get on my head and then somebody
crouch on my yeah crouch on my head
crouching on your head jump and then
Crouch now stand up jumping I'm jumping
stand up jump go
work
oh [__] oh [__]
somewhere jump oh God you you've locked
me in oh no I'm good yeah yeah oh God
okay okay you're try rating me good what
the
hell that was a fantastic thing going on
over here God damn
it I got an idea
made Sweet Success me okay no you stand
I am not moving from this
spot yeah there you go all right number
three y stuck uhoh hold on hold on I'm
trying to get myself to stand
up oh damn it all right hold on we've
got this no we've done it twice we can
do it wish I had a gun right now but I'm
dumb I'm stuck again you mean like
fast that's right back off get on me hey
who's got the gun between the two of us
between the two of
us I'm just going to hang out down here
okay roof wait so it's one of us
oh wow W okay I can't believe I sheared
you on so where did the gun go that's I
think it's there where's the gun top no
it's not I think it fell off the back of
the barn and like over flew over the
fence I got some bad news for you guys
the gun is outside the map yep that's
what I hold on hold on before you kill
us before you kill us stop running stop
stop it stop it okay I stop yes let me
try it's only fair let me try and get
out of the map to try and get the gun I
okay all right Adam Adam always do that
too I don't I don't think I have
anything to offer you but God damn it
what have I done now now here I can die
watching TV which I very great option
that's
yeah I speak a lot underage and they
just Giggle and stuff that's what we are
today this High School that are underage
we're not underage are you still
invisible I don't know I don't see him I
just found it really
funny I see you m I become
visible